[Music]
and down memory lane news submitted by
Harry Weiner Harry V that's funny funny
who came up with that one probably a
[ __ ]
AOL has announced they will be shutting
down aim after 20 years
please just stay College students still
use it only they don't use the facebook
messenger they use it as like a secret
like it's our clip type of thing like I
saw it like we're using old technology
yeah those say there was these students
that were using it in Boston they were
like you know going back and forth like
chit chatting it up I was like yo what
the [ __ ] losers you could just use text
message I think it just makes it special
because it's between the home of see I
mean like the homies are using aim I did
like aim back in the date as you could
talk to my 10 people at the same time
hella fast then you can leave those
messages in your profile pill way method
yeah this is a song listening to right
now or whatever that's like Twitter
before Twitter that's what a lot of
people are saying that the AOL like the
aim of way messages would like example
oh yeah look at this person he knew and
she really don't know how to use capital
letters that we know back then you never
used to type that [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] about
I know what that is it was just so much
[ __ ] work I mean like these [ __ ]
would type you have to have a bot and
you could tell like they were
straight-up taking forever cuz they had
it capital you know some people can type
like that you use the bot dude that was
the stupid way to do it yeah well you
just type it in there's programs oh and
then you just type it in the program
ever new Russia the program you you put
like it you can customize it to like you
know baby blue comic stands or whatever
you want to and then it does the upper
case lower case for you I know that
you were a hacker you knew that [ __ ] I
was a hacker this [ __ ] mm I like this
[ __ ] in your yearbook too they would use
lowercase oh yeah and they would fill
all their [ __ ] essays and their
[ __ ] Dominguez questions IQs numbers
four letters yeah I knew what's one that
only wrote in capital letters and she
would always get a bad grade on her
[ __ ] [ __ ] because she wouldn't
puncture with her [ __ ] correctly and it
was an English it was a writing class
she was but that's how I write it's not
correct you can't just use capital
letters all the time
it looks prettier yeah tell her right
now she's watching cool color you
[ __ ] dump [ __ ] yeah are you a really
nice though I'm sorry do you guys
remember these the buddy icon
I never remember those that might be
later some 41 is that what it says yeah
so 41 yeah that would have been later
then dr. evil Chapelle show half baked
no this is all me I only know the little
people and the shirts
yeah didn't you use any of this show I
use uh I was laying my head MSN so I use
hotmail oh you know who use MSN
Messenger my dad
grandma's yeah yeah my friends in Mexico
they would only use that maybe the
agents were up on the a.m. because I
knew Louisville that did help nothing
yeah no white people and the geezers
because very much that's true cos just
has a hotmail account no that was a
trendy thing well I mean you don't count
cuz you're just like 10 years after us
but I still used aim though hotmail was
like one of the things though I remember
it was like popping off especially cuz
it was hot you know like it's hotmail I
remember because I had MSN at MSN calm
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you kind of don't
count either cuz they're just just as
young you know we're the same age
yeah but they they would have still had
it yeah he's just different perfect like
yeah she's Mexican - so she's little
more backwards yeah late adopters for
the technology have you heard of this
thing called cell phones wait didn't we
did you have a oh well account or did
you have a
all account and then had a came
afterwards oh I never had an AOL you
mother when I'm at a m-- I always had
the MSN Gmail pop up dude cuz I remember
I should took over
I remember switching over to Gmail
because I felt like a loser emo popped
up for me at least I remember yeah it
was a loser and that's when I had to get
into the real world
yes that's what I used my real first
name and last name I remember when it
was only in beta and only a certain
amount of people had it and there was
some people in my high school I was like
how'd you get access and forget to get
invited oh yeah I remember them by thing
I don't understand to like it Wells at
the Men's Wearhouse and I was so when
you have to sign up for our tuxedo we
asked for your email so we could contact
you and there's like these like 30
some-odd year old dudes that still
haven't changed their email what they
got EarthLink or some [ __ ] it's like
it's like AZ and gang pay for two to
[ __ ] ten-year-old kids are there man
like change your [ __ ] [ __ ] because
why never changed my email is like what
do you work at dude I want to know what
job you easy yeah and they just haven't
changed it and they would leave the
thing blank and they don't want to write
it down I'm like we need your email and
they're like nah that's cool you need up
on the phone I was like but this is just
in case so you know when you're touches
you know causes problems it goes all
right cool don't read it till I leave
don't read it but I love I don't
I like dicks oh my god yeah so anyway so
here's an example of the profiles Oh xxx
New York female like a s so I signed
into my aim like this was all over
Twitter and everything
I signed in to see if anyone was on
couple people were on I don't want to
talk to any of them so I signed out this
is crazy it's gonna make me wish I did
have one because everyone in high school
had one Oh aim but I was the only loser
how come you didn't get one why are you
so resistant to it I don't know you're
like I'm trying to be underground [ __ ]
that I know I don't know I felt like I
only have one email like I only need one
I don't know
but damn this takes me back Jen so
there's also this little soundcloud
thing where you can hear all the aim
sounds oh yeah I remember that
oh right when you turn on yeah I
remember sounds oh you get the message
yeah he was so weird it was like a place
for you to talk to your friends for you
to flirt with girls without any
accountability you know like you just
kind of did anything like now an ability
like everything yeah like you could just
like flirt with the girl and they could
misconstrued or something else and then
you could deny it no yes yes oh you're
still able to sign into your aim
accounts up until December 15th or
before it's December 15 on December 15th
and on like you won't be able to get on
em anymore but if you do have an AOL
email you'll still be able to access it
it's just a messenger that's shutting
down it actually are the nuts
in 1997 I'm like I remember that year
that's when Princess Diana really 97 I
think I was using AOL and then I
switched over to aim because it's the
same thing no cream is AOL Instant
Messenger right but then it's separated
from AOL and it became its own free
program so if you like back back in a
day yeah it was you you got you get like
AOL 2.0 or like AOL 95 or whatever right
oh yeah and then after the free trial
you have to pay for it unless you carted
someone and you created a free account
after with their credit card or you just
created a screen name that sounds very
familiar
and then you get free access right so
then you get that and then fast-forward
to early 2000 is when people started or
99 or whatever 98 99 that's when people
started using aim and then they had like
a hotmail Gmail or Yahoo Gmail I mean a
yahoo email or whatever and then they
just use their aim what was net zero why
does that bring up oh okay you got like
a desk and you put it in and he can go
online but that was just a browser right
yeah just a bra yeah okay yeah but a AOL
was the [ __ ] though because you had chat
rooms and you could like talk to
strangers and it was really cool aim was
just everybody on your buddy list mm-hmm
no but you can open it up to other
people you can yeah how do you how do
you go to
maybe I'm getting mixed up cuz as long
as somebody has your screen name yeah
they can like contact you oh no that's
what I mean is only your buddy list you
can talk to strangers like the a log I
read something about that that people
would go on chat rooms on me well not
the ones that we had was it an
invite-only chatroom I forgot because I
remember AOL specifically yeah Asians
congregated under the category Japan and
under Japan there was something like
because there was no other like Asian
America or Asia and it was like it was
like Chou's right and then there there
were like all these different categories
like when internet was so [ __ ] sick
it was so hard to watch porn or download
music oh it take baby oh it would be
like a day for a [ __ ] song and then
you'd be telling your friends I got that
song remember it went up guys that went
up yep I still want that [ __ ] it's a
music player you could get skins and you
could change the we're not layout so oh
yeah
I still like whatever better than iTunes
[ __ ] I hate the iTunes player I think
that shows garbages I remember being on
acid and watching my win app you know
like the winner yeah yeah yeah you just
accept oh yeah you just expand it and it
turns into like and then I'm just
staying [ __ ] one hour just like dude
we got lucky cuz we're that generation
when everything started turning into
like color and stuff cuz then my sister
she had the one that was like black and
then the when you type the words it's
just all green well that kind of
computer like ms-dos type [ __ ]
oh that was like in elementary school
when they were teaching us about
computers that's that organ trail
computer yeah that's the old Mac ugh
that game dude that's sad hope you guys
enjoyed that episode of JK news make
sure to stay connected because we're
constantly updating our social media so
follow us at JK films for Instagram and
at JK films for Twitter to watch more
videos click right over here
[Music]